As for the local elections
we have divided competence decisions here
These most important positions
Presidents of provincial cities or
staffing assemblies
It is up to the board of leaders to decide
while yy other letters for example to city councils
to yy are the responsibility of the district leader
In Wroclaw it is Krzysztof tuduj MP
yy I will mark
that we will not enter for sure with
No coalitions with mainstream parties
if we can talk about cooperation with the environment
who have at heart the good of our local homeland
A program
confederation fits perfectly and corresponds
Also in Local Needs
First
we want to relieve the inhabitants of Lower Silesia
As for all taxes
surcharges charges
tribute and so on
yy bureaucratic difficulties yy
which are no big obstacle and beam under the feet
I want to meet the real needs of Wroclaw
Do not serve foreign interests
not to succumb to a unified diktat at the local level
when it comes to car ban zones
called Clean Transport Zones
When it comes to all these
yy implementations and restrictions
Related to the Building Directive
epbd yy and limitation
when it comes to yy way of heating people s homes
yy a know many can not afford heat pumps and other ym
ways of heating
yy we want to give up the so-called cities
fifteen minutes
which do not serve the local good
We care about the environment in a different way.
we do not want
to be imported and put into the lower Silesian
to our yy region of garbage
which are currently put into power
very different among other things worn tires what
is yy higher
in my village is happening
lately there is such self-aggrandizement
No,
I m talking about self-management too.
Will be a candidate for president
So will the presidential candidate.
Details soon